mona amoudé l'homme emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé à l'occasion de la
soixante quinzième assemblée générale un
long discours axé sur la pandémie et les
relations internationales selon le
président de la république il faut
apprendre à vivre avec ce virus et tous
les efforts seront déployés pour le
vaincre écoutez le d'abord je crois en
la science et la connaissance et
l'humanité vaincre à cette pandémie un
remède sera trouvé mais dans cette
attente dont nul ne sait combien elles
durent à chacun de nos pays n'aura
d'autre choix que d'apprendre à vivre
avec le virus et le monde devra
apprendre à vivre avec cette nouvelle
réalité qui s'impose à tous révèlent nos
vulnérabilités nous place devant nos
immédiate responsabilités je vous le
disais plusieurs sujets ont été abordés
le discours a été axée sur les relations
internationales il a mentionné la
situation en libye au liban en afrique
ou encore la relation entre la chine et
les états unis il indiqué que le monde
ne devait pas tourné autour du conflit
de ces deux pays écoutez le il faudra
compter à l'avenir avec ces nouveaux
équilibres qui sont en train de se
définir
il faudra compter sur la force des
bonnes volontés parce que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
résumer à la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis
quel que soit le poids mondial de ces
deux grandes puissances
quel que soit aussi l'histoire qui nous
lie en particulier aux états unis
d'amérique mais fragilité que je viens
d'évoquer nous impose de rebâtir un
nouvel ordre et impose à l'europe de
prendre toute sa part de responsabilité
c'est à dire de porter ses valeurs son
goût de l'avenir et de savoir bâtir des
solutions nouvelles
après la chine et les etats-unis manuel
macron a parlé de l'union européenne
notamment il a indiqué qu'il fallait
rétablir un nouvel ordre grâce à la
cohésion de tous ces pays des 27 pays
membres de l'union européenne plusieurs
thématiques ont été abordées je vous
disait de l'afrique au moyen-orient il
s'est notamment adressé au liban afin
qu'un gouvernement se forme le plus
rapidement possible président de la
république a également félicité la
normalisation des relations entre israël
et deux pays arabes le bassin et les
épées les émirats arabes unis mais il a
également eu un bon pour la palestine
écoutez le la paix au proche orient
reste une nécessité
d'abord pour les israéliens et les
palestiniens mais pour nous tous je me
réjouis qu'israël obtiennent la
reconnaissance de nouveaux pays arabes
c'est une reconnaissance légitime c'est
aussi un gage d'espoir pour l'avenir
pour autant une paix juste et durable
nécessite avant tout de retrouver les
voies et moyens d'une négociation
décisive qui permette aux palestiniens
de disposer enfin de l'ordre
je ne crois pas à une paix qui se
construira sur l'hégémonie ou
l'humiliation
quand bien même celles-ci seraient
compensés par de l'argent car nous
savons trop qu'on ne compense pas
l'humiliation d'un peuple par de
l'argent par ailleurs le président de la
république qui a eu un mot pour la
russie il demande que la lumière soit
faite concernant je cite la tentative
d'assassinât contre un opposant
politique comprenez alexeï navalni et
voilà pour les quelques sujets abordés
lors de ce long discours en discours il
faut le savoir
axé sur les relations internationales le
multilatéralisme surtout l'importance de
la coopération